[Musik]
in der Hauptstadt soll ab Montag nichts
mehr gehen so der Stadt Stillstand Plan
der letzten Generation die in dieser
Woche schon mal vorgelegt hat mit
klebeprotesten fürs Klima Autofahrer
sind genervt die CDU fordert höhere
Strafen und auch die Grünen distanzieren
sich von dieser Bewegung die Aktivisten
wollen dass die Regierung Tempo macht
beim Klimaschutz und das fordert nicht
nur der Expertenrat für Klimafragen
sondern auch viele Bürger aber mit den
Methoden der Demonstranten können sich
die wenigsten anfreunden kleben
blockieren lahmlegen wie radikal darf
klimaprotest sein unser Thema in der
Phönix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ich darf für meine Gäste
vorstellen herzlich willkommen Amy von
bahlen sie ist klimaaktivistin
Pressesprecherin und
vernetzungskoordinatorin der
Organisation letzte Generation ich
begrüße Philipp Amthor von der CDU er
ist fachsprecher für Staatsorganisation
und Staatsmodernisierung und
Vorsitzender der Landesgruppe
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und herzlich
willkommen Prof Robin celikates sie sind
Professor für Praktische Philosophie und
Professor protestforsche hier an der
Freien Universität in Berlin wir warten
jetzt noch auf Irene Mia Litsch von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen die erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Bundestagsfraktion sie ist ja gelernte
Polizistin studierte Kriminologin und
hat eine Menge dazu beizutragen zu
diesem Thema ist aber gerade noch im
Bundestag gebunden sie kommt dann gleich
dazu Frau von Wahlen sie haben
angekündigt mit ihrer Organisation
Berlin soll ähm still stehen ein
bisschen was haben sie schon gemacht wie
erfolgreich lief es denn aus ihrer Sicht
diese Proteste
also wir haben vor allem in den letzten
Tagen
Protestmärsche veranstaltet das bedeutet
ein langsames gehen auf der Straße und
das ist aus meiner Ansicht nach sehr
erfolgreich gewesen weil wir eben
beobachten konnten dass auch viele
PassantInnen sich dadurch einfach
spontan angeschlossen sind und mit uns
gemeinsam gegangen sind es gab aber man
natürlich auch Autofahrer die sehr
genervt waren weil sie nicht weiter kam
es gab auch aggressive Aggressionen
ihnen gegenüber wie begegnen sie dem
ja also es ist natürlich immer sehr
dramatisch dass Menschen überhaupt erst
dazu gebracht werden quasi sich für
diesen Protest einzusetzen das ist auch
für uns eine sehr ja sehr sehr
ungünstige Situation dass wir politisch
immer noch so weit entfernt davon sind
tatsächlich gute Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
umzusetzen dass wir diesen Protest und
diesen zivilen Widerstand eingehen und
es tut mir sehr leid für alle Menschen
auch auf der Straße die jetzt dadurch
aufgehalten werden aber sie sorgen dir
dafür dass die Menschen aufgehalten
werden ja es ist einfach so dass wir
gerade sehen dass es eine riesige Glück
gibt zwischen dem was klimapolitisch
getan werden muss was wir brauchen um
eben die Grenzen des Klimaabkommens
nicht überschreiten und dem was
letztendlich jetzt gerade Realität ist
und was gerade umgesetzt wird und das
ist schlussendlich einfach viel zu wenig
daraus ziehen Sie den Schluss dass sie
diesen Protest machen müssen ja am Tor
wie sehen sie wie ist dieser Prozess mit
ihren Augen legitim die CDU hat ja einen
Antrag gestellt können wir gleich
nochmal drüber reden aber erstmal
grundsätzlich ja also es ist natürlich
so und da können Sie sich alle Umfragen
anschauen wie es um die
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz dieser Form
von Protest bestellt ist diese Akzeptanz
ist in der Gesellschaft nicht vorhanden
hier werden zu Hauf die Grenzen der
rechtsstaatlichen Ordnung überschritten
wir sehen dann das Straftäter zum Teil
verniedlicht werden als Aktivisten und
das erfüllt uns schon mit großer Sorge
und ich glaube wenn man ernsthaft
interessiert ist an der Klimapolitik und
an der gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz für
dieses Thema dann muss man sagen es gibt
wenig Organisationen die der
gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz von
Bewegungen für den Klimaschutz so sehr
geschadet haben wie die sogenannte
letzte Generation den diese Gruppe stößt
auf massive Ablehnung aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft mit ihren Aktionsformen und
das schadet der gesamt Akzeptanz von
weiteren Maßnahmen für den Klimaschutz
und dass ich mit großer Sorge natürlich
hat es wie sehen Sie es als
protestforscher haben sie natürlich
verschiedene Bewegungen im Blick ist das
was die letzte Generation jetzt macht
wie viel ist davon erlaubt was nicht was
ist sinnvoll also zunächst mal glaube
ich muss man unterscheiden zwischen dem
Verstoß gegen einzelne Gesetze die zum
Beispiel die Straßenverkehrsordnung
betreffen und dem beschreiten der
Grenzen rechtsstaatlichen Ordnung sind
gleich zwei wirklich sehr
unterschiedliche Kategorien und auch die
Frage nach der Legitimität kann man
nicht allein mit der mit dem Verweis auf
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz oder auch
auf die Legalität der Protest vom
beantworten also es ist ein klassisches
Phänomen das zu den Ungehorsams einer
protestpraxis die eine große und für die
Demokratie sehr sehr wichtige Geschichte
hat in Deutschland aber auch in USA zum
Beispiel King ist einer der berühmten
Namen in den gezielt einzelne Gesetze
gebrochen werden zum Beispiel durch
Sit-Ins durch Straßenblockaden um auf
gesellschaftliche Missstände Demokratie
identifizierte Ungerechtigkeiten
hinzuweisen um Menschen in die
Diskussion einzubringen vielleicht keine
richtige politische Stimme haben dass
das Argument von vielen Jugendlichen und
Schülerinnen und Schülern gewesen und
die deswegen zu diesem dieser Form des
Protests greifen nicht um die
rechtsstaatliche oder demokratische
Ordnung zu untergraben sondern
tatsächlich um ein sehr wichtiges und
legitimes Anliegen stärken die
politische Debatte einzubringen in dem
Fall sozusagen der Zweck die Mittel also
ist das ist nicht der Fall weil die
Protestform natürlich strikt selbst
begrenzend sind zum Beispiel gibt es ein
explizites und
prinzipiell begründetes
begründeten Verzicht auf Gewalt gegen
Menschen das Zeichen zu den Ungehorsam
aus auch in der Geschichte dieser
Protestformen und das dem man hat sich
auch die Klima Bewegung sehr explizit
und aus prinzipiellen Gründen wie gesagt
er verschrieben deswegen erfüllt mich
ehrlich gesagt er mit Sorge und deswegen
halt ich die Radikalisierung der
Reaktion für viel Demokratie
gefährdender wenn jetzt gesagt wird das
ist quasi Terrorismus das sind
Kriminelle das sind gar keine Aktivisten
damit verschieben wir glaube ich die
Maßstäbe dessen was eine Demokratie
nicht nur aushalten muss sondern das was
tatsächlich auch zum Fortschritte
Demokratie in unserer Gesellschaft und
anderswo beigetragen hat weil mit der
Argumentation mit Verlaub verschieben
sie wiederum dann die Grenzen schon
dessen was wir als rechtsstaatliche
Ordnung in der Gestalt auch der
Strafgesetzbuches gefunden haben nicht
nur Gewalt gegen Menschen des
strafbewährt sondern Nötigung ist
Nötigung und auch um das hier ein
bisschen ins Verhältnis zu setzen man
sagt dann ja gut ein legitimes Ziel
natürlich das Ziel darüber kann man
streiten das ist sinnvoll sich für
Klimaschutz einzusetzen damit habe ich
gar kein Problem aber wenn man sieht
welche Ausmaßes annimmt das
Staatsanwaltschaften in Deutschland die
Staatsanwaltschaft in Europa gegen die
Gruppierung der letzten Generation
ermittelt wegen Bildung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung ein Anliegen hat
ja ein Anfangsverdacht wo es ein
Strafverfahren gibt wenn wir darüber
diskutieren müssen dass das Bundesamt
für Verfassungsschutz mittlerweile
ernsthaft sieht wie das linksextreme
Spektrum diese Protestform nutzt um
selbst
radikalisierungstendenzen aufzubringen
dann ist das etwas was wir nicht
irgendwie verniedlichen dürfen und der
Maßstab da gibt es Unterschiede dass man
sagt ja aus einer sagen wir mal
philosophischen Betrachtung etwas
legitim zu finden das finde ich da die
Teilnehmern
Beleg für Extremismus bei der letzten
Generation und wenn man sich daran
erinnert was wir hatten bei den bei den
Festnahmen bei den reichsbürgern sind
das doch ganz kann man das eine doch mit
dem anderen gar nicht das habe ich auch
nicht verglichen es sind sehr starke
Unterschiede bei dem einen geht es
richtigerweise um den schweren Vorwurf
des generalbundes Anwalts der Bildung
einer terroristischen Vereinigung das
ist etwas anderes als die kriminelle
Vereinigung bei der wir mit der letzten
Generation ja in Phasen zu tun haben
aber eins ist klar überall dort wo diese
Protest vom Auftreten gibt es danach
Arbeit für Polizei
Staatsanwaltschaft anderes mehr und wenn
sie auch ja das können sie verniedlich
sagen ich will nur sagen dass
Bundesverfassungsgericht weil das
angesprochen zum Thema Sitzblockaden ich
finde das nur schon spannend man tut ja
so ungefähr als hätte das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hier in
Persilschein für diese Aktionsform
erteilt hat es nicht wir haben die
Rechtsprechung zur sogenannten Blockade
zweite Reihe deswegen gibt es auch zu
hauptverurteilung Bewährungsstrafen für
viele ihre Aktivisten mittlerweile auch
Gefängnisstrafen durch überzeugende
Entscheidung und das ist nicht so dass
hier Karlsruhe die Verfassung oder die
Rechtsordnung irgendein Persilschein für
diese Protest kommen
gewesen dass das Versammlungsrecht auch
lokal auf Autobahnen abdecken kann ja
aber das der Maßstab ist der
strafrechtlich nicht das kann auch frei
bleiben wenn genau dieses
Versammlungsrecht höher gewichtet wird
sie sind auch schon selbst verhaftet
worden wegen der Blockaden waren 20 Tage
im Gefängnis was ist genau ihre
Motivation war sie sagen der Klimaschutz
ist so wichtig an auch jetzt nach diesen
20 Tagen Gefängnis es gibt so Punkt wo
sie wo sie gezögert haben sie waren ja
früher beides vor future aktiv
ja also ich glaube der springende Punkt
ist dass die Bundesregierung gerade die
Verfassung bricht wir wissen dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht 2021 festgelegt
hat dass die Grenzen die im Pariser
Abkommen bestimmt wurden
verfassungsrechtlich bindend sind das
bedeutet es ist verfassungspflicht ein
adäquaten Plan vorzulegen wie wir diese
Grenzen nicht überschreiten und den gibt
es gerade einfach nicht stattdessen gibt
es Maßnahmen von denen wir aber nicht
wissen ob sie in Summe tatsächlich dazu
führen dass diese Grenze nicht
überschritten wird und solange dieser
Plan quasi nicht durchgerechnet wird und
vorgelegt wird ist es ein
Verfassungsbruch und das macht mir
unglaubliche Angst denn sie doch den
Plan durchrechnen und vorlegen anstatt
sich fest zu kleben den kann ich doch
nicht alleine durchrechnen sie sind ja
jede Menge also mehrere hundert
Aktivisten und eine Frage ist kann man
könnten sie nicht eine andere Art finden
die dem Klimaschutz mehr dient also ich
glaube da gerne gleich noch mal auf
unsere Forderung zu sprechen kommen denn
es ist ja so dass dieser Plan natürlich
parlamentarisch erstellt werden muss und
das was wir fordern ist ein
gesellschaftsrat der eben genau dazu
beitragen könnte denn dieser
gesellschaftsrat
hebt quasi diese Fragestellung auf wie
wir es bis 2030 schaffen sozial gerecht
weg von den fossilen Energien zu kommen
und würde ganz klar schwarz auf weiß
aufzeigen wofür ist demokratisch
Mehrheiten gibt und wofür nicht und
damit kann die Bundesregierung dann
einen Plan erstellen und man könnte auch
sagen dass Parlament ist ein
gesellschaftsrat das sind gewählte
Abgeordnete und die das Thema
Klimaschutz ist ja gerade auch mit den
Grünen in der Bundesregierung wir warten
ja gleich noch eine grüne Abgeordnete
ist doch gerade sehr prominent und auch
die Union hat sich den Klimazielen den
Pariser Klimazielen verschrieben warum
reicht das nicht diese Art warum kann
man es nicht im Parlament machen ja ich
frage mich auch warum reicht das nicht
also was wir halt gerade sehen ist
leider dass diese Diskussion und der
Koalitionsvertrag bei weit nicht
ausreichen damit wir diese Grenzen nicht
überschreiten und was ich glaube ist
dass die Bevölkerung nicht in diese
Krise Rasen möchte wir wollen nicht
unsere Demokratie durch die
Klimakatastrophe verlieren oder aufs
Spiel setzen und dieser gesellschaftsrat
würde ja insofern unterstützen dass sie
dann ganz klar schwarz auf weiß hätten
wofür die Bevölkerung tatsächlich
mehrheitlich stimmt und damit dann auch
eine Rechtfertigung abgeben müssten wenn
einzelne dieser Maßnahmen eben nicht
erfolgen das nicht genau die Grundfeste
unserer Demokratie auf die wir uns
geeinigt haben eine repräsentative
Demokratie
die dann sozusagen ja diesen Vertrag
machen können aber es geht nicht darum
dass das alles verpflichtend ist in
diesem gesellschaftsrat sondern es geht
darum dass die Maßnahmen und das ist ja
keine neue Idee solche Gesellschaft
von der Bundesregierung natürlich hat
also ich glaube das sind zwei Punkte
vielleicht nicht das erste ist
Demokratie
ist ein sehr komplexes System zu dem
ganz wesentlich das Parlament Parteien
und Wahlen gehören dass ich aber nicht
darauf reduzieren lässt zudem komplexen
System gehört genauso Protest gehören
Gewerkschaften und soziale Bewegungen
gehören andere Institutionen
zivilgesellschaftliche Art die auch
gesellschaftlichen Gruppen Individuen
Beteiligung ermöglichen und jetzt kann
man darüber nachdenken sich die
Institution der Demokratie auch
weiterentwickeln können Hörgeräte haben
sie schon angesprochen das Problem mit
Bürgerinnen zumindest in Deutschland ist
das in allermeisten Fällen einfach nur
Empfehlung aussprechen können die dann
gar keine bindende Wirkung haben und
damit verpufft ist dann wieder womit
wiederum die passive
situationsbereitschaft meistens singt
weil wenn man eh nur symbolisch sich
beteiligen kann haben die meisten Leute
darauf keine Lust ich bin auch erst
giftig ja die Mercedes
der Wissenschaftliche Dienst des
Bundestages hat genauso festgestellt
dass der Bundeswehr Verkehrsminister
sein gesetzlichen
Verpflichtungen nicht nachkommt also ich
glaube diese Tatsachen kann man nicht
vom Tisch wischen und das ist auch
historisch sagen wir mal normal das äh
der normale Meinungsbildung und
Entscheidungsprozess relativ zäh ist es
gibt sehr viele historische Beispiele
dafür dass es soziale Bewegung Protest
gebraucht hat um überhaupt bestimmte
Themen auf die Agenda zu bringen um den
Display haben wir die Protestbewegung
auch natürlich erst seit gestern
sie haben sich erst in den 80er Jahren
überhaupt ökologischen Problemen auf den
Druck der Straße hinzugewendet ja also
natürlich ist es heute weiter aber das
ist doch nicht erledigt ist doch nicht
von der Agenda verschwindet und es muss
auch immer weitergehen das ist klar
wissenschaftliche wissenschaftliche
einigkeit besteht ich meine Leuten Sie
was der IPC sagt finden Sie das Hotel
von Demokratie
heftig in der Diskussion nach der Frage
was ist jetzt erlaubt was ist sinnvoll
was nutzt dem Klimaschutz die Grünen
sind aus der Protestbewegung entstanden
haben sich dem Klimaschutz sehr
verschrieben was stört Sie an der
letzten Generation im Grunde genommen
gar nichts
oder ich will es mal anders ausdrücken
vielleicht ist die Frage sozusagen auch
nicht zutreffend auf meine Kritik in
formuliert also ich finde schon dass es
ein sehr sehr breiten Protest braucht
der auch gesellschaftlich getragen ist
um auch innerhalb der Politik den
notwendigen Rückenwind zu erzeugen um
auch wirklich politische Veränderungen
zu bewirken wir sind in einer sehr
komplizierten Situationen die Klimakrise
spitzt sich zu ja und ich kann die
Verzweiflung die auch bei dem
Protestaktion mit schwingt ich habe
dafür sehr viel Empathie weil genau
diese Verzweiflung im Grunde genommen
auch etwas war was mich auch in die
Politik getrieben hat um unsere
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen zu retten
und um halt eben auch wirklich
Gesellschaft unterschiedliche
Verbesserung zu erreichen und jetzt sind
wir aber in einer Situation
wir Regieren in einem Dreierbündnis wir
sind natürlich unterschiedliche Parteien
mit unterschiedlichen Zielsetzungen wir
sind gezwungen Kompromisse zu machen und
können nicht sozusagen die reine leere
vertreten und das ist auch in einer
Demokratie der Normalfall und wir
kämpfen sozusagen mit den Möglichkeiten
die wir haben aber es ist natürlich
bedeutsam für uns auch in der Politik
wenn wir wissen dass wir für das was wir
wollen und für das was wir durchsetzen
wollen auch den gesellschaftlichen
Rückhalt haben und Fridays for future
ist ja vorhin als ich jetzt gerade auch
schon mal Thema gewesen die haben es zum
Beispiel geschafft ja also bis in die
Breite bisschen alle Verästelungen der
Gesellschaft hinein wirklich ja
Massenproteste auf die Straße zu bringen
also die konnte niemand ignorieren ja
und es ich habe auch niemanden aus den
demokratischen Fraktionen erlebt der
nach solchen Protestaktionen gesagt hat
nee das sind irgendwie 30.000 Spinner
die da gerade auf der Straße gewesen
sind Kultusministern
und so großer Unterschied genau aber ich
sag mal ich sag mal sozusagen aus der
aus der aus dem politischen Raum habe
ich also nicht nur viel Sympathie erlebt
sondern auch vor allen Dingen Druck
verspürt die groko hat daraufhin
Klimaschutzgesetz gemacht was nicht
hundertprozentig toll war und es wurde
ja später noch verbessert und so klar
aber
ich glaube das Bild was man bei der
letzten Generation erlebt oder was durch
diese Protestaktion erzeugt wird es
halten anderes bei den Fridays oder auch
bei anderen Protesten hat man halt ich
sag mal 100.000 auf der Straße gesehen
und vielleicht ein paar wenige die
gesagt haben das finden wir nicht okay
bei der letzten Generation ist das Bild
ein anderes und ich fürchte einfach und
dass meine Befürchtung deswegen meine
Kritik dass dadurch Rückhalt aus der
Gesellschaft verloren geht für die
klimaschutzbewegung insgesamt oder sie
haben gesagt wenn ich das richtige ist
ein elitärer uns selbstgerechter Protest
ja weil er auch sehr ich sag mal
rechthaberisch daherkommt
Verzeihung also nach dem Motto kapiert
es doch endlich ja die physikalischen
Gesetzmäßigkeiten sind so und wer es
nicht verstanden hat ist selber schuld
und das ist sozusagen die Attitüde die
da mitschwingt aber wie gesagt die
Motivation teile ich ich teile auch die
Intention die dahinter steckt ich
fürchte nur dass es das falsche
Instrument ist und wirklich breite die
Breite der Gesellschaft hinter sich zu
bringen was wir aber brauchen in der
Politik was sagen
was sagen sie denn dazu Frau von Wahlen
wenn wenn so viele Leute sagen ja sie
sie machen gerade sie erreichen gerade
das nicht was Sie erreichen wollen sie
verärgern die Leute und sie leisten eben
keinen hilfreichen Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz also erst einmal es gab ja
die Möglichkeit auf Fridays for future
gut zu reagieren und ein
Klimaschutzgesetz zu erstellen dass uns
tatsächlich schützt dass unsere
Lebensgrundlagen schützt und das ist
nicht passiert nur aus dieser Konsequenz
heraus hat sich die letzte Generation
überhaupt erst entwickelt
es gibt das ist die gute Nachricht auch
heute immer noch Fridays for future und
sie könnten immer noch genauso gut auf
diese reagieren und ich verstehe das
Argument nicht warum wir jetzt für die
Mehrheiten streiten müssen das ist
Aufgabe der Politik und ich glaube da
wäre Punkt Nummer eins dass sie sich
wirklich mal ehrlich machen denn
weiterhin der Bevölkerung zu erzielen
wir befinden uns auf dem 1,5 Grad Fahrt
illusioniert dass wir in eine Zukunft
blicken die schon noch irgendwie in
Ordnung und tragbar ist und das ist
nicht die Realität trotzdem sie
erreichen sie können doch ihre Ziele nur
erreichen wenn Sie die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung mitnehmen und wenn sie so
viele Menschen verärgern dann schaffen
sie das doch erst recht nicht also was
passiert ist ihre Mittel nicht richtig
ich glaube da muss man trennen ich
glaube man kann für mehr Klimaschutz
sein und man kann zum Beispiel auch die
Forderung nach einem gesellschaftsrat
der eben genau das schaffen würde
nämlich uns als Gesellschaft wieder
zusammenzubringen und die Mehrheit
mitzunehmen Mehrheiten ganz klar
aufzuzeigen unterstützen auch wenn man
nicht für die letzte Generation ist also
ich finde das ist doch wirklich dieses
ganze Bild vom gesellschaftsrat das
Parlament versagt
Weltuntergangsstimmung das finde ich ist
kein Bild das irgendwie zukunftsfähig
ist und ich will ja ja
so ich glaube aber schon es bringt doch
nichts jetzt so zu tun ich meine wie
selbstgerecht ist das eigentlich zu
sagen okay es gibt Wahlen die führen zu
einem Ergebnis
das passt einem nicht und wenn die
Politiker dann halt nicht passen
wohlgemerkt jetzt eine linke Regierung
an der die Grünen beteiligt sind wenn
dann das dann schon nicht passt dann
muss jetzt halt ein gesellschaftsrad
kommt das ist aus meiner Sicht im
Koalitionsvertrag
Koalitionsvertrag jetzt kann man über
viele Geräte und expertenräte und Kur
reden ich kann nur sagen selbst wenn es
den gesellschaftsrat gibt dann wird er
nicht einseitig nur die Interessen wie
die letzte Generation in so einem
schwarz-weiß Schema vertreten sondern
dann werden sie trotzdem nicht zufrieden
sein das legitimiert nicht zu dieser
Protestform sie schaden damit der
gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz von
Eintreten für den Klimaschutz und ich
sag das auch mal aus einer Perspektive
aus einem Abgeordneten als Abgeordneter
aus dem ländlichen Raum bei mir haben
die Leute noch mal zum Thema verbrenner
motor Emissionen der Landwirtschaft da
haben die noch mal eine ganz andere
Perspektive als die Menschen in
Berlin-Mitte
ich sage das nochmal da gibt man aber
der AFD Rechtspopulisten und sonstigen
vereinfachern mit ihrer Form des
Protests Munition in die Hand gegen
Klimaschutz im Allgemeinen zu arbeiten
und damit schaden sie dem gesamten Ernte
die Debatten die wir um das Thema
Verbrenner ausführen oder auch Gebäude
Energiegesetz und so weiter und Sie
haben jetzt die Perspektive ländliche
raumgespiegelt die mir durchaus bekannt
ist also das ist da Widerstände gibt und
das ist der andere Perspektiven gibt
nicht mehr das können Sie jetzt nicht
der letzten Generation aber sie geht so
damit Wasser auf die Mühlen von den
Leuten die sagen die sind hier in
Berlin-Mitte
sprach von der Klima Raff sie haben
einen Antrag gestellt wo sie haben sie
mit dem Titel Straßen Blockierer Museums
dran der Lehrer härter bestrafen
Menschen Kulturgüter für radikalen
Protest schützen dafür haben sie keine
Mehrheit bekommen und wollten
verschärferes Strafrecht also da kann
man ja auch sagen sie bedienen eine ja
eine
teilweise
scheinbar zu der Differenzierung fähig
die der letzten Generation fehlt wir
haben ja nicht gesagt letzte
generationsschärfer bestrafen wir haben
gesagt Straßen Blockierer und
museumsrandalierer und das ist eine
Gruppe wo ich mich frage wie soll man
die denn jetzt irgendwie vertreten so
und so kommt noch hinzu ja noch hinzu
jetzt kommt noch hinzu diese
Begrifflichkeit der Klima RF die dann
viel kritisiert wurde worum ging es denn
Alexander dobrill in seiner überspitzen
Äußerung darum dass wir eine
Radikalisierung Spirale jetzt endlich
mal brechen müssen und das ist doch das
Problem man fragt sich doch wo ist denn
bei ihnen irgendwann mal Schluss dann
kommt nach dem Berliner Flughafen kommt
das nächste immer weiter jetzt gibt es
Haftstrafen das ist eine Radikalisierung
gerade die immer weitergehen und das ist
gerade
wo wäre denn für sie das wo sind denn
bei ihrem Protest die Grenzen ihre
Forderungen sind ja eigentlich gar nicht
so Rad sie wollen ein Tempolimit sie
wollen das 9 euro-ticket für alle sie
wollen diesen gesellschaftsrate den ist
ja teilweise auch schon gibt diese
bürgerräte also wo wäre für Sie Schluss
mit wo ist ihre Grenze wo sie sagen da
gehen wir zu weit das haben wir ja auch
immer wieder preisgegeben unsere Grenze
ist ganz klar dass wir die Friedlichkeit
niemals verlassen werden diese Grenze
überschreiten wir auf keinen Fall und
dass wir auch nichts mutwillig zerstören
und ich glaube was wir gerade erleben
ist keine Radikalisierung des
klimaprotests natürlich kommen wir mit
mehr Menschen aber das sind keine
anderen Formen als die die wir in den
letzten Jahren schon angewandt haben der
Unterschied ist doch wie auf uns
reagiert wird und da möchte ich auch
sehr gerne noch mal an sie her am Tor
sagen selbst wenn Sie die gesamte letzte
Generation wegsperren würden
sich kriminell zu behalten das würde uns
schon helfen solange es kein Klimaschutz
gibt der uns verspricht dass wir später
nicht in Verteilungskämpfen landen nicht
kriegen landen werden solange ist das
nicht gibt wird es immer wieder Menschen
geben die auch mittels zivilen
Widerstand darauf aufmerksam machen und
sich dagegen wehren und sich dem in den
Weg stellen
ich würde gerne nochmal etwas
grundsätzlicher fragen wenn man sagt
eine Gruppe ist von ihrer von einer
bestimmten einen bestimmten Ziel
überzeugt und wählt dann Mittel wo viele
sagen das ist rechtswidrig Nötigung all
das
um eben diese Ziele durchzusetzen ist
das ein Unterschied welche Ziele das
sind wenn das jetzt die Reichsbürger
wenn die sich jetzt festkleben an der
Autobahn ist das dann sagen wir dann das
wollen wir nicht bei den klimaaktivisten
sind viele damit sie sympathisch dass
dann besser also für die Rechtfertigung
von sowas am Spielen die Ziele und die
Qualität der Rechtfertigung natürlich
eine riesen Rolle ja also natürlich
Massen Unterschied ob ich
eine private Überzeugung die keine
rechtliche verfassungsrechtliche oder
demokratische Legitimität hat auf die
Straße nicht klebe oder ob ich auf die
auf verfassungsrechtliche Grundsätze wie
die Verantwortung für zukünftige
Generationen verweisen kann ob ich aus
Demokratieprinzip verweisen kann ob ich
auf Urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsverweisen kann
das macht ein riesen Unterschied und ich
fände es auch wirklich wir haben
Differenzierung angesprochen ich fände
es schon sehr gut wenn wir
differenzieren könnten zwischen der
grundsätzlichen Legitimität von
bestimmten Form des Protest die man
nicht kriminalisieren sollte weil es
sehr sehr schnell nach hinten losgeht
das sehen wir in England zum Beispiel
und der Frage ob es strategisch klug ist
und ob es gesellschaftliche Mehrheiten
organisiert wenn man im Berufsverkehr
blockiert in der zweiten Frage bin ich
auch er skeptisch ja ich glaube nicht
dass es politisch so klug ist das zu
machen aber daraus zur Folge dass der
Protest grundsätzlich illegitim ist und
er hatte bestraft werden muss das ist
eine extrem also ersten begriffliche
Verwirrung apropos Differenzierung und
zweitens ist das politisch extrem
gefährlich glaube ich ja diesen Fehler
sollten wir nicht machen und erstmal
sollten wir doch alle protestiere gleich
bestrafen natürlich
verfassungsrechtslage das ist völlig
wir können noch mal das
Bundesverfassungsgericht zur
Versammlungsfreiheit und zur möglichen
Straffreiheit auch von Straßenblockaden
studieren ja das ist eigentlich sehr gut
drauf Entscheidung die
Grundsatzentscheidung zur
Versammlungsfreiheit ist klar darauf
abstellt dass es nicht nur nach einer
Bewertung rechtlichen Bewertung der Form
des Inhalts der politischen Botschaft
der versammlungsweise geht also da
kommen wenn der Richter entscheidet ist
das legitim ist es besonders
hat doch zum definitionsbestandteil dass
ein Gesetz gebrochen wird die sagen ja
nicht wir brechen gar kein Gesetz
natürlich ja und in dieser hinsichtlich
dass das bestraft aber nicht härter
bestraft wird weil das motiviert ist das
ist die Gefahr das muss man verstehen
politische Motivation wenn Sie den
Antrag gelesen hätten aber da geht es
nicht um Klima Protest da geht es um die
Frage von Straßenblockaden und Museum
sehr wohl die strateversammlung
akzeptiert also das muss natürlich die
akzeptieren den Schutzbereich aber
trotzdem recht fertigen sie dadurch
nicht eine strahlfreiheit nein wir
versprechen
in die Justiz die auf Basis der
bestehenden Gesetze und auch auf Basis
der bestehenden Strafrahmen und
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten die wir haben
also da bin ich ganz bei Ihnen also man
muss jetzt nicht anfangen weil ein
bestimmte Protestformen nicht passen
anzufangen sozusagen den Protest noch
zusätzlich zu kriminalisieren über das
was ohnehin schon strafrechtlich
relevant ist und das was auch
gerichtlich wie sie es auch ja
beschrieben haben schon mehrfach sauber
ausgeurteilt ist also ich hätte da
ehrlich gesagt das das ist ja überhaupt
gar nicht großartig hinter der Regelfall
aber wo ist Ende der antust ja gar nicht
der Punkt der Punkt ist doch der ich
habe Vertrauen und unsere Justiz die auf
Basis der bestehenden Gesetze das alles
ganz ordentlich machen wird und mal
entscheidet sie so mal entscheidet sie
so immer im Einzelfall orientiert und
genauso ist es doch richtig doch worum
es doch jetzt hier in der Debatte geht
ist doch jetzt gar nicht die Frage
werden hier im Einzelfall Gesetze
gebrochen oder nicht und wir werden sie
am Ende bestraft das gar nicht der Punkt
sondern der Punkt ist der zumindest aus
meiner Perspektive was dient am Ende
sozusagen dem Ziel in dem wir total
einig sind ja also wir streiten alle für
mehr Klimaschutz ja ich in meiner Rolle
sie in ihrer Rolle und sie wählen
bestimmte Protestformen wo ich jetzt
sagen würde die sind vielleicht der
Sache nicht hundertprozentig dienlich ja
und ich finde darüber kann man trefflich
diskutieren was am Ende sozusagen dem
Klimaschutz nützt und was ihm vielleicht
eher schadet dazu habe ich eine Meinung
die habe ich eben gesagt aber ich finde
wenn wir über
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen diskutieren und wir
jetzt hören wie er am Tor z.B oder
andere argumentiert dann muss ich halt
eben feststellen wenn auf diese Art und
Weise protestiert wird dann führen wir
halt eben genau solche Debatten und
reden eben nicht mehr über das wichtige
Thema Klimaschutz was ich sehr
bedauerlich finde
ich die protestieren genau
wie sehr Frau von Bahn sind sie
enttäuscht von den Grünen die in ja für
den Klimaschutz sehr klar einstehen aber
natürlich Kompromisse machen müssen mit
der ampelkohle zum mit den anderen
Parteien der ampelkollektion ist das ist
das eine Partei wo sie sagen dass weil
die nicht mehr in die Arbeit tun die sie
erhofft haben müssen Sie diese Proteste
machen also ich bin gerade enttäuscht
von jeder Partei die im Bundestag diese
Entscheidungen trifft diese
Entscheidungen die uns eben in eine
Zukunft entlassen die bei weitem nicht
rosig aussieht und wo ich mir wirklich
einfach riesige riesige Gedanken und
riesige Angst davor habe
wie wir das noch regeln wollen wir
werden zu wenig Wasser haben zu wenig
Essen allein ein Drittel der ernten in
Deutschland wird bis 2050 ausfallen und
da sind gerade alle Parteien im
Bundestag mit beteiligt und treffen
nicht die richtigen Entscheidungen das
heißt aber konkret Richtung grüne sagen
Sie nicht das ist auf die setzen wir und
auf dass sie die auf eine bestimmte Art
beeinflussen wollen noch mal also ich
verstehe total dass es eben auch
schwierig ist weil Kompromisse getroffen
werden müssen und genau deswegen glaube
ich aber auch dass dieser
gesellschaftsrat da eben diese Lücke
schließen kann weil die Kompromisse
natürlich einfacher zu treffen sind wenn
man ganz klar auf Papier stehen hat
welche Maßnahmen die Bevölkerung sind
müssen in einem gesellschaftsrat auch
Menschen wie ein Anton mitnehmen und das
ist schwierig ja und ich meine gucken
Sie sie ja also das ist vielleicht nicht
schwierig aber es ist die Lebensrealität
dieses Landes die dazugehört dass Leute
im ländlichen Raum das Leute aus
verschiedenen Lebensrealitäten in
unterschiedlichen Blick auf das Thema
haben und dann können Sie natürlich hier
in Berlin Mitte im Fernsehstudio sitzen
und sagen die sind alle blöd die haben
uns nur noch gesagt ich sage das könnte
man dann vertreten die Realität ist aber
gesellschaftsrat hin oder her der wird
doch nichts anderes groß bilden als das
was uns die Demoskopie im Moment sagt
und wenn sie in die Demoskopie schauen
dann ist ihre Protestform stößt die auf
breite Ablehnung
es geht darum Lösungen für den
klimakollapsfähig in der Gesellschaft
weder im Parlament noch in Umfrage
das ist der Punkt denn da geht es dann
eben nicht darum wieder gewählt zu
werden es geht nicht um
parteieninteressen sondern es geht
wirklich darum die großen
wahrheitsinteressen die über den
Parteien Interessen stehen
immer unsere staatlichen Institutionen
nicht die Parteien aber nicht das
Parlament wir haben doch eine
parlamentarische Demokratie das verstehe
ich ja genau Koalitionsvertrag steht
festgeschrieben dass diese
gesellschaftsräte stattfinden soll und
die das einzige was wir verlangen ist
einerseits dass Deutschland dann darüber
Bescheid weiß denn dieser Bürgerrat
Klima der schon stattgefunden hat da
wussten gerade mal 9% der Bevölkerung
von dass der überhaupt existiert und so
nimm dann die Masse natürlich nicht mit
und wir wollen dass ihr zu einer
konkreten Fragestellung stattfindet
nämlich wie wir es sozialgerecht bis
2030 schaffen weg von den fossilen
Energien zu kommen weil das die
physikalischen Grundlagen sind an die
wir uns halten müssen vom wichtig sind
diese gesellschaftsräte und genau also
wir nennen sie bürgerräte im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert und wir
beraten darüber dass wir im Laufe dieser
Wahlperiode zwei bürgerräte machen
wollen zu unterschiedlichen
Fragestellungen die Fragestellung werden
übrigens international also auch mit
ihrer Fraktion zusammen vereinbart die
dazu zu Debatte stehen und das Prinzip
ist ja so dass der Bürgerrat am Ende zu
Empfehlungen kommt ich finde es auch
sinnvoll das zu machen ja einfach weil
es natürlich immer gut ist sich auch
Expertise immer von außen zu holen und
nicht sozusagen über diese selbst
Bespiegelung zu machen sondern und das
ist ja auch das Prinzip im
Gesetzgebungsprozess wenn wir Gesetze
machen dann machen wir auch immer
Anhörungen ja und wo dann
unterschiedlicher Sachverstand dann auch
zu Wort kommt der Unterschied glaube ich
zu ihrem Modell ist dass das was der
Bürgerrat am Ende beschließt oder
empfiehlt dass das Parlament an einem
Verpflichtung hat sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen und ich habe ihr
Modell immer so verstanden dass es
sozusagen eine unmittelbare rechtliche
Bindung entfaltet und das ist natürlich
mit dem was wir als parlamentarische
Demokratie verstehen nicht nicht
kompatibel darum geht es aber auch nicht
genau
dann sind wir ja sozusagen bei Modell
schon mal ähm ähnlich ich will aber noch
ein Satz sagen weil sie haben eben ihre
Enttäuschung zum Ausdruck gebracht mit
Blick auf das was im Bereich des
Klimaschutzes passiert und ich kann es
total gut verstehen und gerade auch an
uns Grüne werden da ja sehr hohe
Erwartungen gerichtet ja einfach weil
wir wahrscheinlich jetzt in der
Koalition auch als diejenigen da stehen
die noch am ehesten dieses Thema
repräsentieren aber ich will einfach mal
sagen dass es ja nicht so ist als wenn
wir nichts fürs Klima erreicht hätten ja
also ich meine coole ausstieg um 8 Jahre
vorzuziehen Verbrenner aus auf EU-Ebene
Gebäude Energiegesetz machen wir
ungefähr 30 Prozent aller CO2-Emissionen
kommen aus dem Gebäudebereich also all
das wird natürlich dazu führen dass wir
den CO2-Ausstoß drastisch senken ja und
das ist mit dem Tempolimit das kriegen
sie nicht hin haben sie recht
da sind wir wieder auch beim Thema
Kompromiss und auch bei anderen
Maßnahmen machen wir natürlich
Kompromisse aber also aus meiner
Perspektive ist es einfach total wichtig
dass trotz aller Szenarien die natürlich
im Raum stehen die sie alle trefflich
beschrieben haben und vor denen ich
persönlich auch große Angst habe ganz
ehrlich ja ich bin ich habe Familie ja
also dass man dann aber trotzdem in die
Situation kommt dem Klimaschutz
mindestens in Schritten näher zu kommen
oder dem was erforderlich ist und wir
kämpfen natürlich für jeden Schritt
Schritt
gemacht
natürlich auch auch eine größere
politische Kraft entfalten wollen wir
den Rückhalt aus der Gesellschaft
brauchen so und da sind wir wieder genau
bei dem Punkt also Protest die natürlich
die Breite der Gesellschaft abbilden
sind da sehr hilfreich und andere Formen
wiederum nicht also deswegen ich bin da
ganz bei Ihnen was sie eben beschrieben
haben der Protest ist das eine man muss
sich aber auch als Aktivist oder als
Aktivistin ständig hinterfragen meine
Ansicht nach ist es noch dienlich dient
ist der Sache oder hilft es eher nicht
so wie ich das als Politikerin waren die
sie führen innerhalb ihrer Gruppe
definitiv also wir schauen uns immer
wieder an was wir natürlich als nächstes
machen möchten und hinterfragen dafür
auch wie es bisher gelaufen ist genau
und ich möchte ganz gerne noch mal ganz
kurz zu diesem gesellschaftsrad
ich würde das gerne werden
Zeit haben würde ich gerne aber was
anderes Fragen das geht ist heißt ja die
letzte Generation
waren Proteste von Schülern oder damit
fing es auf jeden Fall an also inwieweit
ist so eine Art Protest einfach ganz
klar an juckt gekoppelt und ist das
etwas wo dann die der Rest der
Bevölkerung die älteren sowieso denken
naja oder wo es um so eine klassischen
Konflikt geht die Jugend geht auf die
Straße und die anderen regen sich drüber
auf wir sind genervt davon ja also
Protestbewegung haben es meistens so an
sich dass ich eher aus den jüngeren
Bevölkerungsschichten rekrutieren jetzt
im Fall der klimaproteste gibt es glaube
ich zwei interessante Neuerungen das
eine ist dass es tatsächlich um eine
existenzielle Betroffenheit dieser
Generation geht die durch Fridays for
future
Massenwirksamkeit in der Gesellschaft
verankert auf die Agenda gebracht worden
ist und zwar auf eine Weise die sich
eben nicht ausschließen ließ als das
sind nur wieder die üblichen Spinner die
Radikalen und so weiter das waren die
eigenen Kinder das musste man irgendwie
ernst nehmen das war glaube ich ein echt
entscheidender Schritt und auch Vorteil
taktische Vorteil dass es diese
und und das haben die auch durchgehalten
gegen anfindungsversuche von SPD von CDU
und anderen ja und das zweite ist dass
die Bewegung sich natürlich auch immer
stärker als transnational vernetzte
Bewegung verstehen muss nicht weil das
also sie haben angesprochen man kann mit
einem
Gesetzespaket in Deutschland und auch
mit einem gesellschaftsrad dieses
Problem nicht angehen das heißt aber
nicht dass die Protestbewegung all das
leisten können muss ja ich habe vorhin
gesagt Demokratie sein komplexes
Ökosystem das Spielen kompeten eine ganz
bestimmte Rolle die Verantwortung
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz konstruktive
Lösungen und so weiter zu generieren zu
entwickeln liegt vor allem bei den
gewählten Politikerinnen und Politikern
das ist genau die Rolle die glaube ich
den Parlament auch zukommt aber wir
wissen historisch und das haben auch
konservative sozusagen wie Niklas
Luhmann festgestellt ohne die
Protestbewegung der 80er Jahre hättest
dieses ökologische Bewusstsein gar nicht
gegeben man braucht man braucht diese
Protestbewegungen sind nun mal ich habe
ungemütlich Kriminalität
Grundgesetz wir haben das Gespräch und
da gab es auch Maßnahmen die übernimmt
natürlich ein anderer Maßstab auch den
wir hier jetzt erleben ist einfach eine
systematische Verniedlichung von diesen
Aktivitäten die einfallstorte des
geringematische Kriminalisierung von
Protest und ich habe noch mal
hingewiesen dass die grundsätzlich
unterscheiden sollten zwischen der
Legitimität von bestimmten Protest von
auch von Straßenblockaden ja und der
Frage ob sie politisch effektiv klug
mehr herzbluten sind unterschiedliche
Fragen jetzt glauben wir die Mitte und
Legalität sind einfach
ehrlich zu sein Differenz auch
dieser Straßen Blockaden irgendwie
vielleicht sich in den Gruppen mal
zusammensetzen und inhaltlich noch mal
überlegen was könnte die Idee sein ja
dann würde doch vielleicht mehr
rumkommen als ein gesellschaftsrat das 9
€ Ticket also ich meinte doch gar nicht
im Verhältnis zu dem Protest der O
machen dafür damit lösen wir die
Klimakrise von diesen konkrete Angst
haben auch nicht
momentanerisch sein finde ich ja darum
kümmern wir uns ja auch aber ich besuche
dann lieber anstatt mich irgendwo fest
zu kleben besuche ich lieber mein
Max-Planck-Institut für Kernfusionen
Greifswald da könnten viele von ihnen
ein Rundgang machen da haben sie mehr
gelernt vielleicht als ich irgendwo fest
zu kleben
auf das was sie planen Frau von beiden
ab Montag haben sie gesagt wollen sie
noch mal mit 400 Menschen hier Berlin
lahmlegen in einem großen Umfang
erzählen sie uns ein bisschen was wollen
sie machen es wird wieder diese Protest
mehr gegeben es wird Blockaden geben es
wird aber auch sehr viele Proteste im
Regierungsviertel geben die sich eben
ganz klar an die Verantwortlichen
richtet an die Menschen die eben gerade
noch den Klimaschutz blockieren
vielleicht noch mal eine kurze Frage wer
finanziert eigentlich ihre Bewegung
also wir haben verschiedene Spender das
sind einmal Großspender zum Beispiel der
kleine emergency found und ganz ganz
viele Menschen die einen monatliches Abo
zum Beispiel abgeschlossen haben also
monatlich einen Betrag bezahlen oder
einmal Spenden machen und all die
Sekundenkleber die sind auch teuer wir
finanziert in die kaufen wir tatsächlich
dann privat für uns ein genau also es
gibt keine Sponsoren nee wir wurden
angefragt aber beim abgelehnt okay weil
das stelle ich ja auch sind ja auch
Kostenfaktoren ist was wird dann
passieren wird das also gibt es
Überlegungen zu sagen ja wenn das jetzt
nächste Woche hier im Regierungsviertel
noch mal richtig rund geht bzw still
steht dass sie sagen ja dann setzen wir
uns noch mal mit der Gruppe zusammen
unten Forderung Tempolimit 9 € Ticket
ist ja was wo man sagen könnte könnten
die Grünen doch hinter stehen ja ich
meine das ist ja auch nichts was wir
nicht schon gefordert hätten oder auch
schon gemacht hätten also ich meine
Umsetzung
ist glaube ich unbestritten aber wie ich
eben auch schon sagte wir sind natürlich
in einer Situation wo wir halt eben auch
politisch Kompromisse machen
das mit dem Tempolimit also ich sehe da
nicht wo deine Einigung sein soll wir
haben das 9 Euro Ticket gemacht und
haben daraus etwas Neues entwickelt ja
und auch kann man sagen 49 Euro sind zu
teuer aber ich finde trotzdem das ist
einfach auch ein Paradigmenwechsel also
im in der Ticket hat aber auch nicht so
eine Redaktion der Verkehrsinformation
wirklich beigetragen ja das war
vielleicht auch zu kurz da also ich
meine das muss man auch mal sehen aber
da liegen jetzt auch keine Zahlen wo
ganz ehrlich nee das war vielleicht aber
das ist ja eine ganz andere Diskussion
aber um auf Ihre Frage zurückzukommen
also wir sind ja dauernd im Gespräch ja
also es ist jetzt nicht so wir reden ja
auch jetzt miteinander ja oder ich war
vor ein paar Tagen ja auch noch in einer
anderen Sendung und habe da auch mit mit
jemandem von der letzten Generation
Gerät also es ist ja nicht so als wenn
wir nicht im Gespräch sind ja also und
das ist aus meiner Sicht auch gar nicht
der Punkt ja also das jetzt hier die
Verantwortlichen das irgendwie nicht zu
kennen das nehmen würden ich deswegen
komme ich noch mal auf meinen
Ausgangspunkt zurück am Ende des Tages
sind wir einfach darauf angewiesen dass
die Gesellschaft mitmacht so und wenn
durch eine Protestform der Eindruck
vermittelt wird dass die Gesellschaft
nicht hinter Klimaschutz steht und das
ist das Bild was also was wo ich fürchte
was ausgestrahlt wird dann haben wir
natürlich auch insofern ein Problem weil
wir dann natürlich Debatten führen immer
dann wenn es um das Thema Klimaschutz
geht ja dann wird irgendwie gesagt ja
guckt euch das doch mal an diese
Proteste will das denn überhaupt jeder
dann kommt der Amthor und berichtet
wieder aus dem ländlichen Raum und sagt
die Leute finden es nicht gut vielleicht
haben Sie da nicht nur 5%, ich bin im
ländlichen Raum groß geworden also
was wäre denn das was wir denn genau ihr
Rad was wäre ihr Rat an die an die
Aktivisten von der letzten Generation
damit das was sie ja die Sorgen die sie
haben damit man ihn die nehmen kann und
damit eben mehr für den Klimaschutz
getan ich will nicht schlaumeierisch
sein und Aktivisten gute Ratschläge
erteilen ich glaube da ist man nie gut
beraten nein ja weil wir haben eine
lange-jährige politische Erfahrung
wir haben aber unterschiedliche Rollen
genau also wir haben unterschiedliche
Rollen deswegen also ich glaube ich will
jetzt hier keine Ratschläge geben sie
geben mir jetzt auch keine direkt
sozusagen also wie wir Klimaschutz
durchsetzen sollen nein also ich glaube
was wichtig ist und was uns auch im Ziel
sozusagen eint und worauf wir uns
fokussieren sollten ist wie erreichen
wir gesellschaftliche Mehrheiten für
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen und wie können wir
diese gesellschaftlichen Mehrheiten in
politische Mehrheiten umwandeln weil
dann können wir natürlich auch relevant
etwas durchsetzen im Moment gehen wir
Schritte zum Klimaschutz wir gehen
zugegebenermaßen kleine Schritte sie
könnten größer sein aber ich glaube
größer werden sie erst wenn wir die
gesellschaftlichen Mehrheiten hinter uns
haben und sie in politische Mehrheiten
umwandeln können aber ich glaube da ist
eben genau dieser Gesellschaft hat das
was wir dann gemeinsam wofür wir
gemeinsam streiten ich glaube das haben
verstanden
Atomkraft Bewegung gesehen ich glaube
ohne die hätten wir jetzt ich am
Wochenende die letzten Atomkraftwerke
abgeschaltet also der Kohlekraftwerke
die sieht man einfach daran sieht man
einfach dass eine Protestbewegung
natürlich auch gesellschaftliche
Mehrheiten erzeugen kann an der die
Politik am Ende nicht vorbeikommt und
dann haben wir gute Ergebnisse
wie groß oder sehen Sie eine Gefahr der
wirklichen Radikalisierung die sehe ich
momentan nicht vor allem nicht auf
Seiten der Bewegung was mich sorgt ist
dass die Krise sich also das ist klar
nicht wissenschaftlich da die wird sich
zu spitzen und wenn weiterhin die
politischen Antworten auf diese Krise
innerlich war bleiben wird sich
natürlich auch die Reaktion darauf
radikalisieren das ist das ist die
Gefahr nicht dass die Klimabewegung wie
sie jetzt existiert sich radikalisiert
dass ich nicht und da stehen wir
vielleicht in der Diagnose auch nicht
mit überein aber ich sorge mich eher
darüber dass diese Schere weiter aufgeht
die Frau noch am Anfang angesprochen hat
zwischen der Objektivität der Krise und
die Problemdruck und der mangelnden
Antworten die wir darauf formulieren und
wenn sich das zuspitzt würde seine
irgendeine Form das ist bei Krisen so
nicht dann wachsen auch die
gesellschaftlichen Unruhen damit wir
sind gespannt wie äh ja wir sehen es
Anfang der Woche dann in Berlin die dann
ihre Aktionen sind und wie die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger darauf reagieren
vielen Dank heute delikate ist bei mir
und Frau von Bahn für diese Diskussion
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen das war
die königsrunde in dieser Woche jetzt
gibt es weiter mit Phoenix der Tag und
Maja Weber bis dann tschüss
[Musik]